[Musique]
volkswagen le géant allemand de
l'automobile qui a annoncé vouloir
changer de nom regarder s'appeler
désormais volkswagen
un petit clin d'oeil à son passage à
l'électrique pour faire oublier
accessoirement le diesel gates c'est la
communication des groupes que vous lui
faites revenir avril tout le monde ya
cru
c'est parti à toutes les lignes dépêche
de l'afp il ya une dépêche de l'afp et
des confrères ce matin de la presse
écrite et crif de votre saga n'a changé
non bon lui ce franchement franchement
j'avais pas le faire à chaque fois que
je joue à chaque fois que je dis son
prénom ça peut être jours oui c'est
vraiment nul plutôt bon
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
je donne mission 2010 cet été en école
d'infirmière et du coup je travaille
dans le bâtiment rien là bas et j'ai
voulu réaliser mon rêve de petite fille
puis oui vous avez bien choisi votre
talent pour devenir infirmière ce film
prouve on en a besoin
l'heure du couvre-feu était passé hier
soir est pourtant sur les quais de saône
à lyon quelques jeunes profitaient
encore de la lumière du jour
quelques heures plus tôt il était même
plusieurs centaines à danser parfois en
verre à la main souvent sans masque sur
le nez deuxième manche où vous affrontez
bien sûr sur un thème pour commencer
l'automne et jean castex est ce un
homonyme
est ce un pseudonyme ou c'est peut-être
jean castex on va voir on va voir
transmission pour moi c'est jean
trudelle latéraux parfait moi qui adore
les roses hervé il a misé dans le mille
car contact pourtant ça voilà pourquoi
j'ai encore ce week-end cherche t il pas
trouvé voilà bon
[Musique]
alors j'ai trouvé une phrase qui m'a
laissé pantois sur le site de santé
publique france les cas contacts de cas
contacts ne sont pas des cas contacts
hors variant je laisse cette phrase à
votre réflexion
le laboratoire britannique astrazeneca
obtenu l'autorisation de changer le nom
de son vaccin
il faut désormais l'appeler vax evry ya
c'est pas vraiment plus fascinant qu'est
ce que ça va changer
bar où on va peut-être oublié avoir pu
être épaulé faut arrêter de polémiquer
bon monsieur messier a fait de la
politique on le sait j'ai tout au fond
de commerce mais si pas du tout plaisir
à critiquer je regarde les choses telles
que les fruits la même rengaine sur tous
les plateaux mais c'est pas grave il a
rien sur eux ils s'aiment pas et vous a
pas donné mais pas vidéo gag à l'époque
c'est vrai que vous sur les plateaux
vous êtes aussi prolixe que baudelaire
ans a serré son style à lui un jeu sous
la ceinture de la mer 10 femmes à des
fidèles on les remercie
merci de nous avoir suivis va tendre que
patrick vous résume les mesures plutôt
que d'aller les suivre en direct sur
d'autres chaînes de télé bah ouais ça
s'appelle de la contre-programmation les
règles qui sont en vigueur dans les dix
neuf départements en vigilance renforcée
ces règles seront étendues à tout le
territoire métropolitain
dès ce samedi soir et pour quatre
semaines
l'image part de l'elysée et est envoyé à
boulogne billancourt à la régie de tf1
pourquoi tf1 car cette semaine c'est tf1
qui s'occupe du pool tf1 envoie ensuite
l'image un dispatcheur globecast orange
qui est situé en plein centre de paris
dans le 3e arrondissement rue des
archives oui pourquoi pas on va écouter
l'extrait parce que j'ai entendu il m'a
rendu macro et donc je ne suis pas sur
ce jeu
pour en deux
à trop
vous voyez le trouble que j'ai eu un
style c'est cette boîte qui distribue
les images aux chaînes qui le veulent
qui raque car au rac les grosses chaînes
paye 8580 euros les chaînes tnt paye
6630 euros les radios elle ne paye rien
car le son est gratos quand emmanuel
macron va chez le médecin c'est parce
que le médecin est malade et quand il se
lave les mains c'est le savon qui
devient propres voilà le type de message
que l'on peut lire depuis la publication
d'un article du monde dans lequel
l'entourage du chef de l'état se dit
admiratif de ce président devenu
quasiment épidémiologistes et une phrase
de jean michel blanquer a été
particulièrement remarqué je le cite le
président a acquis une vraie expertise
sur les sujets sanitaires
ce n'est pas un sujet inaccessible pour
une intelligence comme la sienne mais
tous les goûts dessine une admiration
tourner en dérision sur les réseaux
sociaux macron marche sur l'eau il a
aussi gagné le tour de france par hasard
en rentrant à l'elysée et puis il a
envoyé arnold schwarzenegger l'hôpital
en lui serrant la main
et puisque l'avenir se demande parfois
ce qu emmanuel macron lui réserve
rendez vous ce soir à 20 heures le
couvre-feu à 19 heures sera maintenant
tenus partout
le télétravail qui est sans doute la
mesure la plus efficace
le télétravail sera systématisé et
j'appelle tous les travailleurs et tous
les employeurs à y avoir recours à
chaque fois qu'ils le peuvent
les commerces seront fermés sur tous les
territoires métropolitains
selon l'âge liste déjà défini dans les
dix-neuf départements aujourd'hui
concert à deux trois sacs et des jets de
bras cassés
il ya un développement de ces temps
différent où on cherche plus une société
plus douce plus molle plus lente bleus
mis en garde et bienveillante ou demi
molle mais où on est un peu comme dans
un cocon
je ne crois pas
les en train de voler avec un piège
[Musique]
la télé ça brasse tellement de choses
que je jeune âge la brasse coulée ici et
voilà quand vous regardez pas notre
émission donc je crois que je vais vite
prend fois alors qu'est ce que vous
faites là bas j'ai obéi à ma fille qui
m'a dit arrêtez de vous ennuyer à la
maison avant
[Musique]
mais c'est dingue
je vous assure je suis à cinq mètres et
je ne vois pas le truc
ah ah
et là on a un atterrissage de piano oui
effectivement pas si courant donc vous
vous ennuyez je m'ennuie vous est
contrainte de regarder la télé cette
liste aurait un peu je comprends je vous
déteste sous le siège